Über 1000 Spieler, die Wetten abgeschlossen haben. 100 von ihnen wurden nun gesperrt. Der Liga-Betrieb in der zweiten und der dritten Liga, der ist gerade ausgesetzt. Acht Haftbefehle wurden erlassen gegen Schiedsrichter und den Präsidenten des Erstligisten, Elyip Spor. Ihr habt vielleicht vom Wett-Skandal in der Superliga und der Türkei mitbekommen. Wir wollen jetzt darüber sprechen, hier im Rasenfunk, mit Gökhan Yagmur von transfermarkt.de. Und jetzt geht's los. Das erstes Publikum, der Rasenfunk.
Nach 25 Jahren als Trainer und 35 Jahren als Fußballer, habe ich noch nie etwas ähnliches gesehen. Es hat eine Dimension, die über alles geht, was unterstehbar ist. Und ich denke nicht, dass ein Club, ein einziger Club, ein System zerstören wird.
Als der Trainer von Fenerbahce. Und diese Zitate, die werden jetzt natürlich gerade rausgekramt. Gökhan, schön, dass du hier im Rasenfunk bist. Dich wird es wahrscheinlich auch nicht überrascht haben, jetzt den Josi gehört zu haben.
Hi. Ja, in der Tat nicht. Aber es war trotzdem noch mal schön, ihn so reden zu hören. Das hat auch mal ein bisschen so ein Lächeln auf meine Lippen gebracht.
Ich meine, das ist ja jetzt gar nicht so lange her. Wie blickst du denn jetzt so rückblickend auf das, was er damals bei Fener gesagt hat? Weil er hat damals ja quasi schon systematische Korruption und Benachteiligung von Fener der Liga vorgeworfen. Interessanterweise aber auch, nachdem man selber mal einen strittigen Elfmeter bekommen hat, hat er auch gesagt, also das gibt es ja alles gar nicht.
Ja, also grundsätzlich ist das jetzt. Das war auch da nichts Neues. Man wusste das irgendwie immer vorgehalten im Mund oder es geisterte immer rum. Nur, man konnte nichts richtig beweisen. Und dann, als Jose das dann gesagt hat, war für mich, ja, da kommt ein Star-Trainer in die Türkei und war für mich nicht verwunderlich, dass er dann sagte, sowas habe ich noch nie erlebt, obwohl ich hier schon in anderen großen Ligen unterwegs war. Die Türkei ist einfach in Sachen Fußball, wie soll ich sagen, da passiert immer wieder was. Also ich glaube, ich kann mich auch kaum noch an eine Saison erinnern, wo mal nichts passiert ist. Also das geht noch weit vor Corona tatsächlich. Da seitdem nur, also Corona mit einbezogen, nur immer ist irgendwas. Nur muss ich sagen, dass das natürlich auch so einer wie Jose Mourinho dann eben, wie seine Art Nummer ist, gerne in ein Westnest sticht und dann sich im Nachhinein ein bisschen wundert, dass da eben Gegenwind kommt und er dann bewusst auch provoziert hat. Ich finde, wie er es gemacht hat, den Ansatz eben nicht gut, überhaupt nicht gut. Es ist so, dass in der Türkei der Fußball etwas anders ist, also nicht jetzt von den Spielregeln her, aber so wird anders wahrgenommen. Und dann sollte man nicht so an die Sache rangehen, wie er es macht.
Also wie meinst du das jetzt?
Ja, ich fand es gut, dass er da ein bisschen nachgebohrt hat, weil es waren wirklich teilweise Entscheidungen, wo ich dachte, wow, das kann man auf die Qualität der Schiedsrichter zurückführen, auf die Zusammenarbeit des Wars und des Schiedsrichters und so weiter und so fort. Man kann es aber auch natürlich in andere Sphären ziehen, wie eben im Hintergrund von Funktionären und irgendwas wurde gedreht, gedroht und gemacht. Das hatten wir schon öfter. Ein Präsident kommt rein oder ein Funktionär kommt rein in die Kabine und droht teilweise den Leuten, wenn ihr hier nicht gewinnt, kommt ihr hier nicht lebend raus und so weiter und so fort. Also das hatten wir schon alles gehabt, aber ich weiß nicht, ob die Art und Weise das aufdecken zu wollen, so zu machen, wie es Jose Mourinho gemacht hat. Wir haben ein Gegenbeispiel mit Dominic Tedesco jetzt gerade aktuell, der sich einfach nur auf die Mannschaft konzentriert. Das sagen natürlich auch viele, das finde ich viel besser. Das ist gut, aber auch er weiß eben, dass manchmal komische Sachen passieren. Er sagt sich aber, es ist so jetzt, ich versuche mit meiner Mannschaft dagegen zu halten. Und das tun sie auch und auch gut. Wenn das Team nämlich gut ist, sind Fehlentscheidungen dann nicht mehr so schwer. Und bei Mourinho war das eben mal ein anderer Fall. Aber dass da jetzt was dran ist oder auch dran war, ist jetzt natürlich mehr oder weniger bestätigt worden. Jetzt mit dem Wett-Skandal. Und ich sage auch bewusst Wett-Skandal und nicht Wett-Manipulation, weil es im Moment erstmal nur ein Skandal ist.
Ja. Gleichzeitig ist natürlich die Problematik damit, jede Fehlentscheidung, die es gibt überall in jeder Liga auf dieser Welt, die wird dann eben vermeintlich aufgeladen. Denn jeder einfache Fehler könnte auch eine bewusste Fehlwahrnehmung gewesen sein. Und was ich eben auch so interessant fand an der Art und Weise, wie José Mourinho die Kritik geübt hat, deswegen habe ich das auch noch drin gelassen im Intro, war, dass er da dann so was Pauschales draus gemacht hat. Dass er dann am Ende des Intros, haben wir es ja gehört, da sagte er, naja, ihr mögt das ja hier anscheinend. Einige von euch finden das ja toll. Das fand ich auch sehr von oben herab. Wie denkst du darüber, dass dann gleich so was Pauschales ausgesagt wird, über, ich weiß nicht, ob es um die Türkei generell ging oder um Fußball in der Türkei oder die Fans, die Journalisten?
Also wenn ich jetzt ganz nüchtern darauf antworten würde, würde ich sagen, er hat Recht. Er hat einfach Recht. Das ist sehr nüchtern gesagt, weil ich glaube es selber auch, die Türkei, die Türken, die Menschen, die Medien, alles, was dazugehört, ist immer sehr drüber. Und es gibt nur schwarz und weiß. Es gibt sehr, sehr wenig grau. Und ich könnte jetzt hier wirklich ein Riesending daraus erzählen, warum, weshalb es geht auch um Charaktereigenschaften der Menschen an sich. Du kannst alle Probleme, die du vom Fußball hast, kannst du auf andere Bereiche. Das ist ein allgemeines Türkei-Problem.
Aber kann man das so pauschal sagen? Ist das nicht in Deutschland, hätte ich gesagt, ist die Debatte auch auf schwarzen Weiß? Beziehungsweise je nachdem, welche Medien du konsumierst?
Nein, die Debatten in Deutschland, die ich natürlich auch immer mitverfolge, sind sehr viel weit gefächert als in der Türkei. Sehr viel weit gefächert und auch viel komplexer. Oder was man draus macht, man macht es komplex. Oder man geht sehr in Detail, in die Tiefen. Und hier wird das relativ schnell auch weggewischt. Hier geht man auch dann irgendwann weiter in die Tiefen, aber aus eigenen Theorien, aus eigenen erschaffenen Theorien, geht man dann in die Tiefe, aber in eine falsche Richtung einfach. Und man vergisst dann oft die Fakten. Also die reinen Fakten werden vergessen und man geht spekulativ in den Themen rein und dann auf einmal ist man sonst wo und schon sind alle korrupt und sonst was. Und das Problem dabei ist, dass man noch nicht mal sagen kann, dass es kompletter Schwachsinn, weil eben genau solche Sachen dann passieren. So und das darf ich glaube ich sagen amateurhaft Fans sind. Dafür sind sie Fans. Sie sind es aber auch leider die Vereine. Jetzt auch ich werde sie auch nicht pauschalisieren, aber es gibt einfach Funktionäre, die sind unfassbar amateurhaft unterwegs. Die Medien genauso teilweise einfach nur die Seiten füllen wollen, damit sie gefüllt sind und die Experten. Also ihr könnt das jetzt nicht so verfolgen, weil ihr das natürlich dann nicht versteht sprachlich. Es gibt Experten, die gibt es gar nicht in der Türkei. Also dagegen, wenn die Deutschen sagen, ach der Lothar, der erzählt wieder was, dagegen ist Lothar wirklich ein Professor. Das ist noch nicht mal übertrieben von mir. Das ist wirklich, es werden, es werden in Expertenrunden Bananen-Käbabspieße reingebracht, nur um den visuell klarzumachen. Adana hat gegen Fener gewonnen als Beispiel und der Galat-Typ, das ist nämlich immer so einer, der für Galer ist, für Fender, für Bistisch, ist dann ein Kebab vor seinen Augen. Und der Kebab kommt ja aus Adana, so will er mit sagen. Die haben euch schön wie so ein Adana gegessen, wo ich dann denke, ist das hier gerade eine Expertenrunde oder ist das hier gerade ein Zirkusverein? Also wirklich ganz schlimm, auf aller schlimmsten Level und dann, wie gesagt, das habe ich aber eben auch schon gesagt, hat Mourinho Recht, aber eben er ist dort, er ist in diesem Land, er arbeitet in diesem Land. Solche Aussagen dann so zu tätigen, von ihm, also ich mache es, weil ich hier bin, weiter weg mit, also ich möchte jetzt nicht sagen, dass ich jetzt Angst hätte, dort zu reden, um Gottes Willen überhaupt nicht, aber ich habe diesen, ich bin nicht im Geschäft drin, also im weitesten Sinne, ich bin nicht in einem Verein drin, ich bin nicht in dem Geschehen drin, sondern ich bin über die Medien drin. So das heißt, ich habe ein bisschen mehr Abstand, gerade auch weil ich hier in Deutschland lebe und den Fußball in Europa und in der Türkei super vergleichen kann, habe ich sogar noch mehr Abstand als die Medien, die in der Türkei sind. Und kann darüber sehr nüchtern reden und sehe es auch. Aber bei ihm muss ich dann sagen, ja, ich verstehe das, Morini, aber bist du in erster Linie da, um ein Trainer zu sein? Oder bist du da, um alle das System komplett umzukrempeln? Was einem ganzen Land nicht 20 Jahre lang nicht geschafft hat? Oder mehr? Was willst du mit als einzelner Typ machen? Das war halt sehr provokativ von ihm. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das so schlau war von ihm. Aber Recht hat er.
Und es ist natürlich auch ein typischer Mourinho, in dem Sinne hat er damit auch abgelenkt von durchaus einigen sportlichen Themen, die es ja auch gab. Es ist ja nicht aufgrund dieser Aussagen entlassen worden bei Fener, sondern weil man die Champions League Qualifikation nicht geschafft hat gegen Benfica, wo er jetzt Trainer ist. Aber das ist nochmal eine ganz eigene Worte. Das ist Jose Mourinho, die Katze des Weltfußballs. Er fällt immer auf die Füße und hat offenbar mehrere Leben. Das ist wie bei Super Mario. Aber dann lass doch mal in die Fakten reingehen. Kannst du mir denn mal erklären, worum geht es denn eigentlich bei diesem Wett-Skandal? Ich habe ja schon ein paar so Rahmen-Dinge genannt.
Genau. Ja, worum geht es in diesem Wett-Skandal? Es geht um Sportwetten, die getätigt worden sind von Menschen, die in dem Geschäft drin sind. Und ich fange mal gleich von vorne an. Es ist so, dass das, ich glaube, jetzt vor knapp einem Monat, ja, rauskam. Da hat sich der TFF-Präsident dann gemeldet und hat halt gesagt, dass es wohl Verdachtsfälle gibt zur Wettmanipulation. Hieß es damals auch so.
Und TFF muss man ganz kurz sagen, das ist die Turkish Football Federation.
Also die türkische Fußball-Federation, richtig. Genau. Und der Verband und hat damals gesagt, wir haben Verdacht auf Wettmanipulation. Erst mal daraufhin kam als erstes auch direkt erst mal nur die Schiedsrichter wurden dann angesprochen. Außerdem ansprechend auch gleich sogar genannt. Also es kam gleich eine Liste raus, mehr oder weniger. Ich glaube sogar ein Tag später oder sowas kam sofort die Liste raus. Und das waren zig Schiedsrichter von allen Ligen, von der Super League, 2. Liga, 3. Liga, 4. Liga und ich glaube auch der Ball-Liga. Das ist die türkische Regionalliga. Die heißt übersetzt genau türkische Regional-Amateur-Liga. So heißt Ball. Das wurde zusammengesetzt. Und Ball heißt auf türkisch auch Honig. Deswegen nennt man sie die Honig-Liga auch. Und dort wurde wohl überall gewettet. Da war für mich gleich als erstes die Frage erstmal, warum jetzt? Also warum kam das jetzt raus im Oktober? Dann, wo die Champions League und die Europa Cup Spiele begannen, man hat die Liga mehr oder weniger vor ein, zwei Monaten gestartet. Also man ist mitten im Spielbetrieb. Warum jetzt? Also da war für mich ziemlich schnell klar, dass das kein Aktionismus vom Verband war. Das war für mich sehr klar, weil der Verband wird das niemals dann machen, dann, wo man mitten im Spielbetrieb ist. Hätten das vorher gemacht oder eben später. Und dann war auch für mich ziemlich schnell klar, dass irgendwie aus dem Milieu, aus dem Wettmilieu von dort kamen Infos. Ziemlich sicher, dass von dort Infos kamen an den Verband, weil da wohl intern irgendwas, was auch immer lief. Aber so hat man gesagt, und das ist für mich auch noch mal so ein Fakt, der Verbandspräsident Haji Osman Oglu, Ibrahim Haji Osman Oglu, so heißt er. Ich hab ihn jetzt mal schön verdeutscht ein bisschen.
Er hat's gemacht.
Das ist ein Mann, der keine Angst hat, nach vorne zu gehen, der keine Angst hat, die Wahrheit auszusprechen, der keine Angst hat, auch aufzuräumen. Und wer auch immer ihm das gesteckt hat, der wusste das. Und deswegen hat er ihm das gesteckt. Davor, dem Präsidenten hättest du stecken können, das wär versickt. Weil wie gesagt, die Vorwürfe, dazu wollte ich gleich noch kommen, aber das sind teilweise die sind fünf, sechs Jahre alt. Also teilweise haben Leute vor fünf, sechs Jahren so gespielt. Also warum jetzt? Und für mich war es eben klar, weil der neue Präsident da ist, der ist vor einem Jahr in Amt gekommen und das andere ist eben der setzt durch. So und dann ist es halt passiert und dann kam die Namen. Erst mal die Schiedsrichter, dann kam die Spieler und ich glaube, jetzt sind sie sogar noch dabei, Trainer und Funktionäre noch zu durchleuchten. Ja und bei den Schiedsrichtern und den Spielern kamen aber ziemlich viele Namen raus und das waren, ich glaube, was du gerade erwähnt hast, Max, über 1000 auf jeden Fall. Genau, über 1000 Leute, die da, ich sag jetzt mal, angeblich gespielt haben. Irgendwann ging man natürlich weiter ins Detail und schaute und machte und was ist überhaupt passiert. Hier finde ich schade vom Verband, das ist meine persönliche Meinung, dass man die Leute erst mal am Pranger gestellt hat. Erst mal die Namen raus, raus, raus, raus, raus, raus. Hier im Bezug zum Wett-Skandal und schon, ich habe es ja vorhin schon erklärt, die Türken reiben sich dann schnell selber was zusammen und schon wurde spekuliert ohne Ende. Ich weiß nicht, ob das beabsichtigt war oder nicht, aber es rumorte, es brodelte natürlich in den Social-Media-Kanälen und überall auf den ganzen Seiten. Ich habe aber auch Stimmen zum Beispiel gelesen, die dann auch sagten, ja nun wart doch erst mal ab und dies und das, das fand ich auch gut, weil so muss man es erst mal machen, erst mal abwarten. Und schon hat sich das Ganze auch ein bisschen relativiert. Also das Ganze wurde extrem hochgekocht. Ich weiß nicht, ob das, wie gesagt, mediumwirksam sein sollte oder das einfach die Art der Türken ist.
Ich glaube, die Zahlen waren es einfach, oder? Also die Liga hat gesagt, dass 371 Schiedsrichter bei Wettanbietern Konten haben. Das sind 65 Prozent aller Schiedsrichter, die es überhaupt in der Türkei organisiert im Verband gibt. Dann haben sie gesagt, dass davon rund die Hälfte, ein bisschen weniger als die Hälfte, 152 haben Wetten abgeschlossen, sowohl in der Türkei als auch internationale Spieler und sieben Schiedsrichter davon sind betroffen, die in der allerhöchsten, also in der Superleague pfeifen und dann kam eben noch schnell so manche Zahlen raus und das war glaube ich das, was dem Ganzen auch so wie so Benzin ins Feuer war, dass es zehn Schiedsrichter geben soll, die über 10.000 Wetten abgeschlossen hätten und 42 mehr als 1000. Also sprich, da sind wir dann auch nicht mehr bei Leuten, die vielleicht vor fünf, sechs Jahren mal irgendwie mit einem Einzahlungsbrunnen eine Wette oder zwei Wetten abgeschlossen haben, vielleicht auf irgendein Premier League Spiel, sondern da reden wir ja sehr wahrscheinlich von Spielsüchtigen, wenn wir in diesen Dimensionen uns dann befassen. Aber ich fand es interessant, dass diese Zahlen dann eben genannt wurden und ich glaube, das hat auch Internationaltanks für so Aufruhr gesorgt.
Genau. Mir geht es ja auch nicht darum, das irgendwie zu verstecken vor den internationalen Medien und sonst was. Das ist ja auch richtig, das soll ja auch raus. Ich fand es nur schade, dass man sofort die Namen genannt hat. Man hätte ja diese Zahlen nennen können. Weil so, und dazu komme ich gleich, nämlich hast du einigen Leuten, der ist nahm, mehr oder weniger in den Dreck gezogen. Und die tragen jetzt einen Schaden davon einfach. Weil, und jetzt kommt es. Also, du hast gesagt, klar, es gibt Schiedsrichter, sowohl Schiedsrichter als auch Spieler auf der obersten Ebene, die ein Wettkonto haben sollen. So, es wurde recherchiert und es kam raus, dass auf deren türkischen ID und das zeige ich mal gleich nur damit Leute wissen, worüber wir reden, weil ich bin ja selber der türkische Staatsbürger. Pass mal auf, das ist meiner hier. Ich zeige ihn mal kurz in die Kamera.
Muss ich da was pixeln?
Nee, nee, alles gut. Da ist eine Nummer drauf, hier oben. Da oben ist eine Nummer drauf und das ist eine Identifikationsnummer. Die hat jeder türkische Staatsbürger.
Offenbar kann man die nützlich zeigen, wenn du es jetzt hier tust.
Es ist wie gesagt, hier in Deutschland kann man damit nicht so viel anfangen. Du hast natürlich vor, das in der Türkei auszustreifen, da müsste das bitte verpixelt werden. Also genau, deswegen, die ist in der Türkei, diese Nummer ist omnipräsent, die ist, damit machst du eigentlich alles mehr oder weniger. Und über diese Nummern wurden auf Namen von Spielern und auch Schiedsrichtern Wettkonten eröffnet. Und es wurde, ja genau, Bonus-Einzahlung und der Bonus wurde gespielt. Mehrere oder auch nur eine Wette, das ist dann immer verschieden. Und es gibt, und wir reden ja jetzt von dieser obersten Liga, der Super League, und das ist ja, sind wir mal ehrlich, von Interesse. Und da kam zum Beispiel, ich nenne als den Schiedsrichter Sorbay Küçük, Türken werden dem was sagen, die die Super League verfolgen, der ist sogar auch FIFA-Schiedsrichter. Und das war der größte Name, einfach von den Schiedsrichtern. Auf seinen Namen wurde eben genau über diese Identifikationsnummer ein Konto eröffnet und es wurde eben gespielt. Er selber hatte davon aber keine Ahnung. Er wusste davon nichts. Das wurde auch bestätigt von der TFF-Seite aus und wurde auch eingestellt, sein Verfahren. Das gleiche passierte mit zwei Besiktas-Spielern, Necip Uysal und Ersin Destanolu. Ersin Destanolu ist jetzt jüngerer Torhüter, der jetzt gerade zum ersten Torhüter gemacht worden ist, vom neuen Trainer Sergi Nyalcin. Weil Sergi hatte Probleme mit dem ersten Torhüter, den alten Mert Günock, den man noch aus der Europameisterschaft 2024 kennt. Der ist jetzt ins Tor gekommen und spielt. Der andere, Necip Uysal, ist der Interimskapitän, aber der spielt im Moment nicht mehr so oft. Nur für den Jüngeren ist das natürlich jetzt gerade sehr, sehr schlimm, dass sein Name so in diesem Zusammenhang rauskommt. Und auch bei den beiden kam raus, dass eben Leute über diese Identifikationsnummer ein Konto eröffnet haben und aber auch nur diesen Bonus gespielt wurde. Aber auch er selber wusste nichts darüber, Necip auch nicht. Es gab dann ein Interview mit ihm, wo er dann auch gefragt wurde. Er meinte, nein, ich bin nicht traurig über diese Angelegenheit. Ich bin wütend, hat er gesagt. Ich bin wütend, dass gerade jetzt, wo es eben gerade bei ihm läuft bzw. wo er jetzt ins Tor kam und auch im Blickpunkt ist, dass so eine Geschichte aufkommt, für die er nichts kann. Es wurde auch direkt vom beiden staatsanwaltschaftlich gegen Anzeige, Anzeige, danke, gegen Anzeige, gegen unbekannt natürlich erstmal. Aber es wird wohl gesucht, wer da eventuell für verantwortlich sein kann. Denn ich habe es ja vorhin schon gesagt, es könnte natürlich jemand vom Verein sein, der locker Zugriff auf diese Identifikationsnummer hatte. Das wäre natürlich richtig schlimm. Es könnte aber auch jemand anderes sein. Man macht einen Handyvertrag und da muss man das halt auch abgeben. Und die Daten werden gespeichert. So und das wird jetzt wohl ein bisschen untersucht. Und dann will er dagegen Anzeige und dann eben auch wegen des Verleumdnungs dagegen will er auch vorgehen und da merkt er schon. Deswegen hatte ich eben gerade gesagt, finde ich schade, dass man die Namen direkt sagt, anstatt nur die Zahlen zu sagen und dann erst mal zu recherchieren und dann zu gucken, wer hat den wo abgemacht?
Genau, also wie viele Wettenden es sind, weil wenn das wirklich nur einmal den Bonus abgegriffen und dann nie wieder gewettet, also dann reden wir sowieso schon gar nicht von Manipulation, also von Spielmanipulation, weil dann werden irgendwelche höheren Beträge mit dabei. Und das zweite ist, dann muss man auch tiefer nochmals juristisch reingehen und erst mal die Frage stellen, was dürfen die Spieler und was dürfen sie eigentlich nicht?
Genau, ganz genau. Und darauf wollte ich nämlich gleich noch zu sprechen kommen, weil da wurden bei beiden eingestellt. Und jetzt komme ich mal kurz zu dem Strafmaß. Ich lasse jetzt mal die dritte, vierte und die Ballliga weg und nehme nur die Super League und die zweite Liga. Also 101 Spieler haben eine Strafe bekommen. Ich sage jetzt mal kurz die Strafen, die Länge der Strafen, und dann sage ich, warum. Also der bekannteste Spieler ist von Galatasaray Erden Elmale. Er ist auch Nationalspieler, wurde jetzt aber aufgrund dieser Thematik aus der Nationalmannschaft Skala erstmal rausgenommen wieder, aus Sicherheitsgründen. Eine Strafe von 45 Tagen bis hin zu Ali Shashalvudal. Das ist ein Torhüter, der auch ziemlich Super League bekannt ist. Im Moment ist er in der zweiten Liga. Und der hat bekommen eine Sperre von einem Jahr. Hier kann ich nochmal erwähnen, Mettehan Baltaji ist auch ein Spieler von Galatasaray, ein Jüngerer. Und der hat neun Monate bekommen. So und jetzt, um so ein Gefühl dazu zu bekommen, diese krassen Zahlen und auch das, auf die Türkei-Spiele gewettet wurden, ist international. Ich habe auch irgendwie ugandische Liga gehört, aber so what? Die sind korrekt. Die sind nicht falsch. Aber dieser Wett-Skandal ist hauptsächlich und hat einen Hauptkern für die dritte bzw. vierte Liga und die fünfte Liga. Und die dritten von mir aus noch. Dritte, vierte, fünfte Liga. Da ist der Kern. Da sind Spieler auch. Da kann man auch, glaube ich, von Manipulation sprechen, weil es wurde eben auf auch die eigenen Ligen gewettet. Es wurde es aber nicht so groß gemacht, weil es eben nur die dritte, vierte und fünfte Liga ist. Alle anderen Spieler aus der 1. und 2. Liga, ich nehme jetzt mal als Beispiel Erden Elmerle, der hat gespielt, er hat es auch zugegeben, er hat gespielt eben vor fünf Jahren, glaube ich. Da war er noch Amateurspieler bei, war es jetzt Isker Renduns, ich weiß es nicht mehr, auf jeden Fall in einer sehr niedrigen Liga und halt noch im Amateurbereich. Jetzt kommt seine Aussage, Achtung, Zitat von ihm. Ich habe damals eine Wette platziert, war mir nicht bewusst, dass das so komplett auch illegal für uns Spieler ist. Dann kam mein Bruder und hat mir gesagt, das ist illegal, lasst es sein, und seitdem habe ich nicht mehr gespielt. Also er sagt, im Endeffekt hat nur einmal gewettet. Das Strafmaß ist 45 Tage. Bei Jelly Luxell von Samson Spore ist das dasselbe. So, Metterhan Balthasar ebenfalls von Gala, der hat auch früher gespielt, auch als er ein Amateur war. Allerdings waren es hier nicht eine Wette, sondern es waren 1500 Wetten. So, und der hat neun Monate bekommen. So ergibt sich wohl das Strafmaß. Ich habe jetzt diese Sachen vorgerechnet oder vorgezählt. Vorher hieß es, dass die Strafen noch ein bisschen höher waren. Das bei R&L mal drei Monate stand und bei Metterhan Balthasar ein Jahr. Das wurde jetzt so ein bisschen downgegradet und im Endeffekt kam jetzt das raus. Das kam jetzt offiziell von der Prüfstelle des Verbandes, wo die Strafen erhoben werden, kam das raus. Also, es wurde gespielt und das gilt für alle, die jetzt hier auf dieser Liste sind, die in der 1. und 2. Liga sind, in ihren Amateur-Zeiten, Amateur-Bereichen, sprich 5. Liga, 4. Liga, gilt ja auch noch mehr so, mehr oder weniger als Halb-Amateur. Da wurde das gemacht. Und das bringt mich auch zum Schluss, dass ich einfach sage, ja, der Kern ist 3., 4., 5. Liga, weil die Leute dort wahrscheinlich einfach nicht genug verdienen und dann eben dadurch versuchen, an Geld ranzukommen. Und deswegen ist es für mich eben hier sehr, sehr hochgekocht. Weil jetzt muss ich natürlich auch fragen, darf ein Erdan Elmarle, als er 18 oder was war, oder 19, und er spielt in irgendeinem, nennen wir mal hier keine Ahnung, die Landesliga oder Oberliga, ist das da schon verboten oder nicht? Das ist halt so eine, das ist auch so eine Ethikfrage natürlich.
Also es gibt keine rechtliche Regelung. Also juristisch ist es gesehen, es geht ja um dieses Gesetz 6.220 oder irgendwie so, und da geht es aber um Spielmanipulation. Wenn du das machst, dann kannst du drastisch belangt werden von ein bis drei Jahre Gefängnis, oder wenn organisierte Kriminalität involviert sein sollte, sogar noch drastisch mehr. Aber das ist das, nachdem die Staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt, da müssen wir nämlich auch noch dazukommen, weil es gab ja auch noch Ermittlungen auch schon bevor der Verband was bekannt gegeben hat, jetzt im Oktober. Aber das reine Anmelden und wetten, das müsste ja wahrscheinlich eher in den Spielerverträgen oder in den Rahmenverträgen mit dem Verband oder mit der Verbandsmitgliedschaft abgedeckt sein. Und ist es da verboten, sich ein Wettkonto anzulegen?
Genau. Also es ist ja so, erstmal manipulativ ist zumindest in ersten und zweiten Liga nichts bewiesen und ganz im Gegenteil, es wurde sogar eher bewiesen, dass auf Ligen gewettet worden sind. Ich habe gerade die ugandische Liga erwähnt, auf solche Ligen. Wie gesagt, nochmal, das ist eine ethische Frage, weil es kann auch sein, dass es dort...
Das ist ehrlich gesagt ein Anzeichen von Spielsucht. Also wenn jemand auf so eine Liga wettet, damit möchte ich die Liga nicht dissen.
Ja, und vor allem auch, vor allem auch wie manipulativ ist diese Liga, dass man da vielleicht einen Tipp bekommen hat. Hier Wette da drauf, das ist safe, sicher. So. Und das ist dann halt eben, da kann man natürlich darüber diskutieren, was auch immer. Aber die waren im Amateurbereich, sie waren nicht im Profibereich. Und da gibt es eben keine eindeutige Regelung dafür, zu sagen, ja, ja, auch im Amateurbereich. Wie gesagt, es ist verpönt von mir aus, ja. Aber es ist nicht gesetzlich geregelt. Wie gesagt, Manipulation erst recht nicht, aber auch eben nicht, ob man da, oder ob man da ein Wettkonto dann hat oder nicht. Ich kann mal ein kurzes Beispiel nennen, wegen Verpöntheit. Der jetzige Präsident von Fenerbahce, Sadeddin Zadran, war, bevor er Präsident wurde, der Chef von der Wettseite Tuttur. Das ist eine von sieben subventionellen Wettanbieterseiten, die die Türkei zulässt. Und als er dann kurz vor der Wahl war, viele wollten Ali Koch, den vorherigen Präsidenten, weghaben, aber haben auch hier eindeutig gesagt, wir können keinen Präsidenten wählen, der Vorstandsmitglied oder Vorstandsführer von einer Wettseite ist. Dann musste er sich dazu äußern und hat gesagt, ich verspreche, wenn ich Präsident werde, dann bin ich da raus. Er wurde Präsident und er ist raus. Dadurch ist die Seite Tuttur auch am Ende, das ist nur mal so als Nebenbei, weil das kann ich so gut sagen, weil wir auch ein bisschen Vermarktungstechnisch dazu hatten und das ging dann aber auch in die Hose durch diese Geschichten halt. Und so musste er halt dieses Amt aufgeben, um eben Präsident zu sein. Ich möchte sagen, es ist nicht gesetzlich vorgegeben, du kannst kein Präsident sein, wenn du nicht gleichzeitig ein Wettanbieter-Chef bist, jetzt so mal salopp gesagt, sondern es ist ethisch. Also die Leute, die die Fans wollten das nicht. Und daraufhin hat er gesagt, gut, dann bin ich daraus, weil ich ja unbedingt Präsident werden möchte von Fenerbahce. Und das Gleiche kann man jetzt hiermit auch verbinden mit den Spielern. Ich rede immer von der ersten und zweiten Liga, die dann eben trotzdem Strafen bekamen, weil sie gewettet haben, aber weil sie eben nicht auf die türkische Liga gewettet haben, sondern auf irgendeine andere Liga und weil es halt eben vor fünf, sechs Jahren war, wo sie eben noch im Amateurbereich waren. Und deswegen gab es diese milden Strafangaben.
Also sprich, wir müssen es genau voneinander trennen. Wir haben quasi viele Betroffene im Amateurbereich, aber auch einige im Profibereich, bei denen aber jetzt zumindest bei den Beispielen, die du genannt hast, dass schon lange zurückliegt und wiederum wieder in den Amateurbereich rein ragt. Jetzt ist es aber auch, finde ich, und ich habe versucht, auf türkischen Seiten dazu zu recherchieren und so weiter und so fort, habe auch festgestellt, dass was du vorhin angedeutet hast, also jeder Tweet wird dann gleich schon mal als Quelle einfach genommen für einen Artikel. Also es war extrem schwierig für mich, ehrlicherweise dann zu trennen. Deswegen bin ich froh, dass du Zeit hattest für dieses Gespräch. Aber wie empfindest du denn die Transparenz, wenn es eben jetzt darum geht, das jetzt aufzuklären? Also du hast jetzt einige Details genannt. Ich habe jetzt aber nichts gefunden. Vielleicht war ich aber auch nicht gut genug. Wo verbandseitig mal irgendwie aufgeführt wurde, dieser Spieler hat das und das in vor fünf, sechs Jahren gemacht. Deswegen erhält er dieser Strafe. Sondern es waren so ganz viele so kleine Quellen. Und dann konnte ich mich auch nicht immer drauf verlassen, ob das jetzt so stimmt.
Ja, das ist wahr. Also da brauchst du auch nicht weiter suchen. Das ist nämlich korrekt. Vom Verband wirst du solche Sachen auch nicht lesen. Du wirst vom Verband wirst du nur eben das Strafmaß lesen. Der Verband, der TFF aus gutem Grund hält sich eisern an Fakten. Eisern an Fakten. Und auch, ja, ich würde gerne sagen viel an Zahlen, aber wie gesagt, Namen sind ja auch rausgekommen. Aber es sind trotzdem Fakten. Und jetzt würden sie einfach nicht reinschreiben. Ja, der Spieler Erden Elmerle hat jetzt vor fünf Jahren einmal einen Tipp gemacht und das war's. Die schreiben dann eben rein, alles ein bisschen offizieller, dass eben aus der Recherche, die dann hervorging, rauskam eben, oder wie bei den Best-Cheer-Spielern, dass eben keine Wettaktion von Seiten des Spielers zu sehen war, sondern tatsächlich eben über die Identifikationsnummer. Ja, wurde ein Wettkonto eröffnet, aber das Spiel wurde nicht von dem Spieler getätigt oder diese Bonuswetter in dem Fall.
Aber woher kann man das denn dann eigentlich wissen?
Also in dem Fall mit Ersin, dem Torhüter von Beşiktaş, weiß ich, dass die sich da auch mit dem Staatsanwalt getroffen haben alle, mit dem Verband und darüber gesprochen haben und es auch so geschildert wurde und es wurde einfach kein, ja, es gab keinen eindeutigen Beweis dafür, dass das eben nicht so ist. Und dann normalerweise im Strafmaß der Türkei ist es auch so, dass natürlich auch ein eindeutiger Beweis vorliegen muss. Und in dem Fall von allen anderen, die dann gesagt haben, ja, ich habe aber dann und dann gewettet und so weiter und so fort, haben die beiden aber gesagt, nein, wir haben es nicht gemacht. Und es wurde wie gesagt, es wurde herausgefunden, dass über diese Nummer in einem Stadtteil die Wette oder das Wettkonto eröffnet wurde. Das konnte man sehen über die IP, wo zum Beispiel auch Erhan sagte, Ersin sagte, Entschuldigung, ich bin nicht in diesem Bereich von Istanbul. War ich nie. Und dann denkt man auch, ja, okay. Und so hat man das immer ein bisschen ausgeklammert. Und dann irgendwann hat man gesagt, okay, das macht schon Sinn, was er sagt. Und das andere macht keinen Sinn. Und deswegen hat man das dann auch wahrscheinlich dadurch, dass es eben nur diese eine Wette Bonuswette war und auch keine Ahnung, wann das genau war. Das war auch schon ein bisschen her. Das haben die jetzt nicht genau gesagt, wie viele Jahre das war. Haben die dann auch gesagt irgendwann, okay, das lassen wir jetzt fallen, weil das macht so keinen Sinn. Das war eine Sinnfrage einfach auch von dem Verband her. Und das Gleiche bei dem Schiedsrichter, bei Zorbaikücük. Da ging es allerdings ein bisschen länger. Da wurde mehr nachgeprüft, gemacht, getan. Was genau, kann ich jetzt auch nicht sagen tatsächlich, was sie genau geprüft haben. Aber da ging die Prüfung auf jeden Fall länger, weil es hier nämlich um einen Schiedsrichter geht. Da ist ja noch mal so ein bisschen diese Sensibilität ja noch mal eine andere als beim Spieler. Und da kann man aber auch im Endeffekt dann eben, ich glaube, ich konnte die dann soweit ausschließen, dass da eben gesagt wurde, ja, okay, auch hier hat er nichts damit zu tun. Er hätte uns nie gewettet. Es wird wahrscheinlich sein Konto. Ich glaube, wirklich Konten wurden inspiziert. Also die Konten der Spieler und der Schiedsrichter, ob da irgendwelche Aktivitäten in dieser Richtung gab. Ich weiß nicht, in welchem Zeitraum das jetzt nachgeguckt worden ist, wie weit die überhaupt Recht haben dahinter, wie weit man zurückgucken kann und so. Aber, ja, also da wurde richtig durchgefegt. Also es wurde wirklich minutiös alles sich angeschaut, gerade bei den Schiedsrichtern. Und da kam bei den dreien eben nichts raus. Und die anderen haben das eben dann von selber schon gesagt. Und die TFF hat das bestätigt eben auch, wie gesagt, durch diese Konteninspezierung und so weiter und so fort. Die IP-Adressen, ob das so Sinn macht und so weiter und so fort.
Und so relativiert sich dann nämlich die Zahl, also die Zahl, die ich ja auch anfangs genannt habe, über 1000 Spieler. Das sind 1024 Spieler, sollen Wettkonten haben, hat der TFF bekannt gegeben vor vier Tagen. Also wir müssen vielleicht dazu auch sagen, wir nehmen am 14. November auf. Das ist jetzt alles quasi stand jetzt. Man weiß nie, was da noch kommt. 27 von diesen 1024 waren Erstligaspieler. Und da haben wir jetzt eben dann schon einzelne Fälle. Hast du uns ja schon erklärt, wie das dann aufgearbeitet wurde und dass es eben zu ganz unterschiedlichen Sperren geführt hat, von wenigen Tagen bis hin zu ein paar Monaten. Aber das ist dann schon das komplette Strafmaß. Weiter drüber hinaus ging es jetzt bei diesen Fällen noch nicht. Aber wie bewertest du denn dann die Art und Weise, wie der Verband das bisher aufgearbeitet hat? Also es ist ja auch richtig, dass auch aus Datenschutz- und Persönlichkeitsrechtsgründen und anderen wir da jetzt nicht jede einzelne Wette und so weiter sehen. Aber das ganze Vorgehen ist ja schon ein bisschen seltsam und du hast es ja vorhin auch schon mal angedeutet, dass man eben rausgeht mit diese riesen Ankündigungen. Wir müssen gleich noch mal gesondert über die Schiedsrichter sprechen. Ich glaube, das ist noch mal ein eigenes Thema. Aber was jetzt die Spieler betrifft, da ist ja der Vorwurf insofern schlimmer. Spieler, wenn sie auf eigene Spiele wetten, können Spiele manipulieren und dann sind wir auch in einem juristisch anderen Bereich, den ich vorhin genannt habe. Wenn jetzt aber ein Spieler auf ein Premier League Spiel zum Beispiel wettet, dann sollte das zwar eigentlich auch nicht sein, denn das ist nicht richtig und das hat so ein kleines Geschmäckle und deswegen sollten das Profis nicht machen, aber juristisch steckt dahinter gar nichts. Also die Staatsanwaltschaft sagt dann, ja gut, da gibt es ja nicht mal eine Anklage gegen wen denn. Wer ist der Beschuldigte?
Ganz genau. Deswegen kommt die Ethikfrage eben sehr hoch raus und dann gibt es halt eben solche Maßstrafe, die ich eben gerade genannt habe, mit 45 Tagen und so weiter und so fort. Grundsätzlich, der große Kern stimmt ja trotzdem. Es ist ein Wett-Skandal-Manipulation in den unteren Ligen. Die haben stattgefunden. Ich glaube, ein Verein hat sogar 18 Spieler, die da drin sind. Ich weiß jetzt leider nicht, welcher Verein das war. Ich habe das aber gelesen.
Das ist Nassili-Sport. Das kann sein.
Nassili-Sport, ja, das kann sein.
Es gilt ja, dass das vielleicht der Auslöser war. Am 28. April 2024 gab es in der dritten Liga, also davon gibt es ja dann zwei, und in einer von beiden gab es ein Spiel zwischen Ankerasport und Nassili-Sport. Da gab es in 90 Minuten keinen Torschuss, nur zwei Ecken, keine einzige Karte, und es wurden ungewöhnlich hohe Wetteinsätze platziert. Und jetzt kommt der Kicker. Mit einem Punkt war Nassili-Sport vor dem Abstieg gerettet, und Ankerasport war in den Playoffs um den Aufstieg. Und da ging es angeblich los mit den Ermittlungen, und da wurden jetzt ja eben auch vor wenigen Tagen, das fand ich interessant, dann die Urteile verkündet. 18 von 21 Spielern im Kader von Nassili-Sport wurden angeklagt, 26 Spieler insgesamt jetzt mit Sperren belegt, zwischen acht Monaten und einem Jahr. Und auch der Präsident von Nassili-Sport wurde gesperrt. Der hat noch so schön gesagt, wir hatten noch gar kein Geld, wir hätten wir wetten sollen, aber hat die nicht vor der Sperre schützen können. Aber es könnte sein, dass das einer der Auslöser war. Es gibt noch ein zweites Ereignis für eben auch staatsanwaltschaftliche Ermittlungen und das vielleicht auch im Zuge dessen andere Wettkonten, andere Spieler und Funktionäre aufgetaucht sind.
Genau. Ich sage ja, der Kernpunkt sind die unteren Ligen. Und da bin ich auch ziemlich sicher, dass das manipuliert wurde. Ganz klar. Es wird halt jetzt, außer natürlich in diesem krassen Fall von Nazili Spur und vielleicht noch ein, zwei anderen, der Rest wird einfach so staatsanwaltschaftlich abgestempelt im Sinne von, also das Strafmaß und so wird alles verhängt, keine Frage. Aber es ist medial, wird es natürlich nicht hochgekocht. So, aber dort wurde ziemlich sicher manipuliert. Es geht um Existenzen und so weiter und so fort. Deswegen gab es da eben dieser riesen Verdacht des Wett-Skandals, dass dann eben im Endeffekt auch noch andere Spieler oder höhere dazukamen. Das hat das Ganze natürlich einen Oh-Mein-Gott-Effekt gegeben. In der Türkei wird komplett nur noch manipuliert. Aber wie gesagt, es wurde sehr hochgekocht und im Endeffekt kam jetzt heraus, dass das nicht so krass ist. Das sage ich jetzt hier mal in Anführungsstrichen. Natürlich ist es krass, wenn manipuliert wird, aber es geht eben nicht um die oberen Ligen. Es geht ab der dritten Liga los, bis runter eben in diese Ball-Liga. Und da wurde, und nicht vor fünf Jahren, sondern auch jetzt erst neulich, in der letzten Saison wurde eben manipuliert und auch eben gewettet und so weiter und so fort. Auch der, wie du schon vorhin gesagt hast, der Präsident von Ape Sport, die ja jetzt Erstligist sind. Jetzt ist ja noch eine zweiten Liga. Das ist für mich schon eher so ein Ding, wo ich sage, aha, das ist schon für mich ein Skandal, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Bei allen anderen sage ich, also jetzt mit RnL Malo und so ko, sage ich, so what? Aber das finde ich schon, also dass da eben so ein Vereinspräsident dann eben seine Finger damit drin hat, das bringt mich eben dazu zu sagen, eben wie amateurhaft auch die Vereine geführt werden. Und das kann ich aus erster Hand sagen, weil ich das selber erlebt habe, wie amateurhafte Vereine in der Türkei geführt werden. Und das ist so der Grund, warum ich eben Mourinho am Anfang einfach bei allem Recht geben kann, nur weil eben genau solche Sachen passieren. Und wenn dann eben jemand im Wett-Skandal verwickelt ist, ein Präsident in der zweiten Liga, das ist schon echt krass, in der zweiten Liga. Ich weiß nicht, worauf er gewettet hat. Das ist nicht rausgekommen. Wahrscheinlich hat er auch mitgemacht in diesen unteren Ligen. Davon gehe ich jetzt mal aus.
Also wenn es Haftbefehle gibt, muss es ja eigentlich einen manipulativen Charakter geben haben.
Genau. Und das ist für mich der eigentliche Skandal.
Jetzt hat aber ja auch Jose Mourinho sich vor allem auf Schiedsrichter bezogen. Und das ist ja das zweite Thema. Und wir hatten jetzt quasi ein Spiel, das könnte zu Ermittlungen oder beziehungsweise es hat sich ja zur Ermittlung geführt. Und in deren Zuge könnten auch nochmal andere Dinge rausgekommen sein. Das war ein Ereignis. Es gibt aber noch ein zweites Ereignis, wo einige Beobachterinnen und Beobachter sagen, vielleicht hat das auch dazu geführt, dass die Staatsanwaltschaft Ermittlungen aufgenommen hat. Also das wissen wir. Die hat sie aufgenommen. Und vielleicht ist in Zuge dieser Ermittlungen eben auch noch was herausgekommen, was jetzt dann zu dieser etwas merkwürdigen getimten Pressemitteilung und der ganzen Aufregung Ende Oktober geführt hat. Und zwar am 5. Februar in diesem Jahr, 2025, trägt Yaza-Trid Yaza Kemal-Ugolo zurück, denn es ist ein Foto aus einem Casino in Nordzypern aufgetaucht, bei dem er am Spieltisch zu sehen ist. Und er konnte dann auf Rückfrage nicht nachweisen, dass er diesen Aufenthalt dort selbst bezahlt hatte. Und komischerweise konnte auch seine Einreise nach Zypern nie belegt werden. Deshalb wurde er zurückgestuft von der Schiedsrichterkommission und dem Verband und hat daraufhin seine Karriere beendet. Und ich habe vermehrt gelesen, dass auch das zu Ermittlungen geführt haben könnte, denn im April 2025 ist es dann ebenso, dass zwei Staatsanwaltschaften Ermittlungen gegen Schiedsrichter beginnen. Später werden die dann zusammengeführt und die Istanbuler Staatsanwaltschaft hat jetzt den Hut auf. Was ist denn zu diesem Rücktritt, Anfang Februar zu sagen?
Das kam sehr viel später heraus. Als das damals zu dieser Zeit der Fall war, hatte man andere Vermutungen. Weil es war so, dass, du wirst dich erinnern, letztes Jahr, wie gesagt, es sind ja viele Sachen passiert in der Türkei, wurde ja ein Schiedsrichter nach dem Spiel von einem Präsidenten, von Ankara Gücü, mit einer Faust ins Gesicht geschlagen. Daraufhin haben sich alle Schiedsrichter zusammengesetzt und auch gestellt und haben dann auch verkündet, dass sie einfach auch sicherheitstechnisch Angst haben. Weil so was natürlich in der Türkei immer wieder passieren kann. Man sieht auch andere Fälle jetzt nicht nur mit den Schiedsrichtern, auch mit den Spielern und so, dass Gewalt im türkischen Fußball da ist. Und das war natürlich so ein Novum, dass dann der Vereinspräsident einen unparteiischen angegangen ist. Und das war so ein Novum, wo dann auch viele Leute dann auch sagten, ich glaube, ich höre auf. Also die haben nicht gesagt, ich höre jetzt auf, sondern die haben damit sehr deutlich gespielt. Das gab es auch schon ein bisschen vorher mit Schiedsrichtern wie Firdert Aidenus, der schon vorher aufgehört hat. Aber sie haben alle vor ihrer Zeit aufgehört, die sie eigentlich hätten an die Grenze gehen können, wie eben ein G. Night Juggles damals. Auch der musste viel, also die Schiedsrichter haben ja viel unter Druck gearbeitet, unermesslichen Druck. Du musst dir vorstellen, ein Schiedsrichter wie G. Night Juggles, der das WM-Halbfinale 2014 pfeift und mehrere Finals in der Champions League oder Europa League und dort weniger Probleme hat als ein random, naja random will ich nicht sagen, aber als ein Türkei-Superleague-Spiel mit einem der großen vier Mannschaften. Oder ein Derby, sagen wir mal ein Derby. Das ist natürlich eine Katastrophe an sich. So, mit unfassbaren Druck, den sich hier glaube ich keiner vorstellen kann, den ich mir selber auch nicht richtig vorstellen kann, weil ich bin ja nicht drin. Nur, was ich von außen sehe. So, und dann kam diese Aktion, dann haben die meisten gesagt. Und so wollen wir das nicht und so weiter. Und kurze Zeit später hat eben dann Uju eben dann auch gesagt, ich höre auf. Und die Vermutung war für mich klar, das lag halt daran, das lag daran, dass eben er keine Lust mehr hatte auf diesen Druck und so weiter und so fort. Jetzt, wo natürlich dann Monate später das rauskam, dass er dann halt eben auch in Zypern gespielt hat und so. Ja, das wirft natürlich ein ganz anderes Licht an eben. Die haben auf die ganze Geschichte. Und dann eben zu, also, ich will jetzt nicht damit sagen, oh mein Gott, die Schiris sind echt hier der letzte Dreck. Das ist nicht der Fall. Das sind gute Leute, gute Menschen, einen kenne ich sogar auch privat, gute Menschen, die halt eben mit dem Druck, der in der Türkei, im türkischen Fußball einfach da ist, schwer klarkommen. Es ist soweit, dass das, wie gesagt, dass in den Spielen der Wahr die Oberhand nimmt. Und der Schiedsrichter eigentlich nur noch ein Medium ist, der da für den Wahr die Entscheidung trifft, weil sie sich selber nicht mehr trauen, eigene Entscheidungen zu treffen. Wenn ich mir das in Deutschland anschaue und ein Deniz Aytekin sagt, wir versuchen immer trotzdem natürlich unsere Entscheidungen, die hier einfließen und nicht vom Wahr, wünsche ich mir das in Türkei auch. Aber das ist eben nicht der Fall. Die sind wirklich nur noch Marionetten vom Verband gegen die Medien, gegen alle einfach. Die werden so ein bisschen hin und her geschobst. Und deswegen habe ich gedacht, ja, ich verstehe, er will aufhören. Deswegen, ganz klar, dass das jetzt, wie gesagt, mit dem Glückspiel dahinter war, ist auch so eine Sache. Wenn wir nicht diesen Druck hätten, den wir in der Türkei haben und der wäre im Casino gesehen worden, dann wäre so dieses, hm, vielleicht ein bisschen empört die Leute und was weiß ich, um wäre gut gewesen. Aber durch die Situation, die wir einfach in der Türkei haben, ist es so hoch explosiv. Dieses ganze Fußballgeschäft ist so hoch explosiv in der Türkei, als ob es da um die Weltmeisterschaft oder um alles geht. Keine Ahnung, da ist ja schon wirklich, das ist ja unfassbar viel Geld steckt da drin. Sagen wir, wie es ist, die Mafia steckt dahinter und so. Es ist so viel Geld und so viel dahinter Macht und so weiter und so fort, dass man, oder man sieht es an den Augen der Spieler, einfach sieht, es geht der Spaß verloren an dem Sport. Fußball ist ja ein Sport und der Spaß geht verloren. Ich sehe selten Leute lachen oder witzeln auf dem Feld, wie ich das sonst in der Liga sehe oder in der Premier League, Bundesliga, in internationalen Spielen, wo sie auch mal ein bisschen klopfen auf die Schulter und ein bisschen noch Spaß machen. Das siehst du nicht, vor allem nicht bei türkischen Spielern. Wenn dann noch einer kommt und noch eine Hand schüttelt und so, dann ist das vielleicht mal Ossi-Man oder keine Ahnung. Das sind so Stars, die kennen das so, dass Fußball ja auch eigentlich Spaß bringen soll. Das ist auch eigentlich ein Pitch. Man ist auf dem Platz und gibt Leistung. Du merkst bei den türkischen Spielern richtig, wie der Druck dort ist. Man ärgert sich über Fehler so krass, dass man da weint, also wirklich immer weinend ist. Und es geht dann nicht um Abstieg oder um, weiß ich nicht was, sondern einfach ein normales Liga-Spiel. Und dann denke ich so, da kriegt man solche Vibes wie 1994, Kolumbien, der Abwehrspieler, der da einen Fehler macht und danach erschossen wird. Diese Vibes kommen dann zu dieses, wie viel Druck darf auf einem Spieler sein? Wie viel Druck darf auf einem Schiedsrichter sein? Und da sage ich dann halt eben ja, also ja, er war in Zypern, hat gespielt und, aber ich sehe da persönlich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht das Problem, wie es gemacht wird, sage ich jetzt mal.
Ich meine, es ist halt so eine schwierige Mängelage. Also der Raum, in dem sich Schiedsrichter in der Türkei bewegen, der ist hochexplosiv. Du hast eben diesen Fausschlag damals 2023 schon angesprochen. 2024 hat Fener aus Protest gegen das Schiedsrichterwesen im Supercup-Spiel damals nur die 19 aus Feld gestickt und die sind nach einer Minute wieder runtergegangen. Auch das hat internationale Schlagzeilen gemacht. Dann konnte das Derby von Fener gegen Galer nur stattfinden, weil man mit Slavko Vincic, internationalen Schiedsrichter, dafür eingeflogen hat. Generell wurden auch beim VAR schon mal internationale Schiedsrichter eingesetzt, um eben gewissen Vorwürfen zu begegnen. Also das zeigt einfach nur, wie sehr von dieser Seite her Druck auf Schiedsrichter ausgeübt wird. Öffentlichkeit ist sowieso klar, das können wir uns alles vorstellen. Und jetzt hast du aber ja ein Wort gesagt, ich denke, da sind manche zusammengezuckt, nämlich die Mafia. Du wirst mir jetzt nicht sagen können, wie sie genau involviert ist, aber ich glaube, dass das eben bei diesem Rücktipp von Ugulu schon eine Rolle gespielt haben könnte und weshalb es vielleicht auch nicht irrelevant ist, wo er im Casino saß. Denn so, wie ich es jetzt gelesen habe, ist es gerade in Nordzypern oft so, dass hohe Wetteinsätze auf Super League und andere Spiele gesetzt werden. Das heißt, da gibt es Verbindungen und wenn er dann eben nicht nachweisen kann, das war eine private Reise, hier ist übrigens mein Flugticket, was ich selber gezahlt habe und dann bin ich eingereist und dann bin ich ausgereist, dann ist das definitiv noch keine Indizienlage, die irgendjemanden schuldig spricht, aber dann verstehe ich, warum auch eine Staatsanwaltschaft sich einschaltet und wenn er zurücktritt, dann legt es ja zumindest den Verdacht nahe, dass er also im positivsten Fall wollte er sich dem Druck nicht mehr aussetzen und hat gesagt, ich habe keine Lust mehr zu pfeifen. Das war jetzt so ein bisschen das, was du gesagt hast, was man damals dachte, als man noch nicht von diesem Foto wusste und so weiter und so fort. Im negativsten Fall könnte man aber auch sagen, er ist der Erste von vielleicht mehreren Schiedsrichtern, bei dem klar wurde, da sind noch andere Interessen im Spiel als eben nur Spiele zu leiten.
Also ich möchte das nicht ausschließen. Das kann ich gar nicht. Nicht in der Struktur, die wir in der Türkei haben. Aber eines muss man erstmal noch dazu wissen. Zypern, Nordzypern, der türkische Teil von Zypern, ist die einzige Möglichkeit für Leute aus der Türkei überhaupt Lücksspiel zu betreiben. Ins Casino zu gehen, Roulette zu spielen, Blackjack oder was auch immer da ist. Weil in der Türkei ist es verboten. Das heißt, könnte auch nüchtern gesagt sein, er wollte einfach im Casino gehen.
Also jeder ein Trip nach Vegas quasi.
Genau. Also es ist praktisch das Vegas für die Türken, Nordzypern. Und ich kenne so viele Leute, die dann sagen, rach, hier übers Wochenende fliege ich mal rüber. Und dann machen wir ein längeres Wochenende und geben der Gas. So, dass da natürlich Strukturen leichter funktionieren, mafiasische Art, ist glaube ich klar. Ist wie auf Malta genauso, eben wie auf Zypern. So, weil in der Türkei ist das einfach ungleich schwerer. Da gibt es auch, kann ich auch sagen, da gibt es auch Etablissements, wo man spielen kann und so weiter. Die sind aber eben verdeckt und ich möchte einfach sagen, es ist ungleich schwerer, dort was zu machen als in Zypern. Deswegen, klar, sind dort die Wetthöhen und die Wettanbieter ja auch sehr viel größer. Weil in der Türkei, das kann ich mal ganz kurz einmal ausführen, gibt es eben nur einen Wettanbieter, der staatlich ist, IDDA. Das sind auch die einzigen Wettanbieter, die Filialen haben in der Türkei. Und dann gibt es eben noch sieben subventionierte Wettanbieter, die aber hohe Standards genügen müssen. Bzw. die müssen gewisse Richtlinien durchgeführt haben, damit sie überhaupt eine Lizenz bekommen in der Türkei. Einer davon war Tuttut, von dem ich eben vorhin erzählt hatte. So. Und dann sind halt eben, die Quoten sind im Rahmen alles, also darauf wird geachtet. So. Und dann, ich weiß auch, dass natürlich viele andere Wettanbieter gerne versuchen, in den türkischen Markt reinzukommen, was aber nicht funktioniert. Da sind sie rigoros. Also die wirklich klatschen dort an der Wand. Da kommt eben keiner rein. Und das weiß die Wettindustrie auch. Aber in Zypern eben kann jeder Anbieter, also du kannst jeden Anbieter und jeden, ich sag jetzt mal, jeden Anbieter im Internet und jeden Anbieter im Darknet. So. Und da ist es, glaube ich, eben so der Fall, dass dort diese, diese, diese mafiosischen Äste sich eben sehr verbreiten. Und der Fokus natürlich darauf ist. Und dann, wenn dann eben ein Schiedsrichter dort ist, so diese Kombination ist absolut explosiv. Und deswegen habe ich gesagt, möchte ich das nicht von der Hand weisen. Aber ich persönlich glaube eben nicht, dass der Schaltkammalurloh da was mit zu tun hat. Auch aus dem Grund einfach, weil also ich sag mal schon, das wäre schon arg dumm. Das wäre schon sehr arg dumm von ihm in der Position, die die Schichtlicher zu der Zeit sowieso hatten. Also ziemlich unter Druck zu sein. Dann sich noch, also wenn er in diesen Strukturen mit drin ist, wissentlich nach Zypern zu fliegen und dort im Casino gesehen zu werden.
Ohne Mütze und alles, also sogar ich habe ihn erkannt auf dem Foto.
Also das wäre schon arg dumm. Das ist so, wenn ich aus rein menschlicher Sicht denke, dann würde ich sagen, das macht für mich keinen Sinn. Aber wie gesagt, meine Hand ist vorgelegen. Dafür würde ich natürlich nicht.
Wir wissen es nicht, aber es liegt eben nahe, dass zumindest vielleicht auch dieser Fall, also diese beiden Fälle, die werden immer so in Verbindung gebracht mit den Ermittlungen der Staatsanwaltschaft. Man weiß nicht genau, was da der Auslöser war, kann natürlich auch was anderes gewesen sein. Wir wissen aber, dass ab dem Frühjahr in diesem Jahr eben dann ermittelt wurde. Für wie wahrscheinlich hältst du es denn, weil du vorhin gesagt hast, vielleicht hat der TFF da einen Tipp bekommen, dass er mitten im laufenden Spielbetrieb, kurz bevor es international losgeht, diese komische Pressemitteilung da verschickt und damit die ganze Lawine ins Rollen bringt. Für wie wahrscheinlich hältst du es, dass es vielleicht auch die Staatsanwaltschaft war, die gesagt hat, wir haben hier Dinge gefunden. Und es scheint ja jetzt auch so zu sein, TFF und Staatsanwaltschaft, die arbeiten ja, du hast es ja vorhin beschrieben, jetzt auch in Teilen Hand in Hand.
Definitiv. Also das kann es auch absolut sein. Ich habe halt nur gesagt, Fakt war für mich, dass das eben kein Aktionismus vom Verband selber war. Weil das von dem Zeitpunkt her...
Dafür war der Zeitpunkt weit.
Genau, macht keinen Sinn. Ob es ein Tipp aus der Wettszene war oder eben von der Staatsanwaltschaft, die dann gesagt haben, wir haben jetzt echt genug Beweise dafür, dass das und das, das würden wir jetzt gerne durchziehen. Und ich eben gesagt habe, der Präsident des Verbandes, Ibrahim Haji aus Manoglu, der ist ein Typ, der dann sagt, hier kämen wir jetzt mit dem Besen. Das muss jetzt gemacht werden, weil er ist wirklich menschlich, ist er gar nicht so mein, meine Art Mensch, weil ich mag seine Ansichten auch viel nicht so. Aber er ist einer, der sagt Gerechtigkeit nach vorn. Das, das muss man ihm einfach zuguteilten, ist so. Und da zieht er auch eiskalt durch. Das, das schätze ich auch bei ihm, das rechne ich ihm auch hoch an. Und dann kann ich mir vorstellen, dass eben wenn die Staatsanwaltschaft gesagt hat, so und so, da machen wir es jetzt. Dass er das dann gesagt hat. Weil sonst, wie gesagt, rein von alleine, glaube ich nicht, dass die TFF, dann sagt, jetzt machen wir es. Es war wahrscheinlich auch schon Druck von der Staatsanwaltschaft auf ihn und er dann gesagt hat, dann machen wir es jetzt. Dann müssen wir es halt eben jetzt machen. Und dann hat er es gemacht. Aber dass es gemacht wird, wäre bei ihm keine Frage gewesen.
Und so kamen wir eben dazu, dass sie eben gesagt haben, dass 65 Prozent aller Schiedsrichter ein Wettambieterkonto haben und 152 davon auch Wetten abgeschlossen haben. Diese 152 haben eine Woche später dann in der gemeinsamen Erklärung alles abgestritten. Allerdings haben wir eben zum einen die paar Schiedsrichter, also zehn Schiedsrichter, die über 10.000 Wetten abgeschlossen haben. Da klingelt die Spielsucht zumindest bei mir, muss ich sagen. Aber nur meine persönliche Meinung. Und angeblich soll auch der Vorsitzende der Schiedsrichterkommission ein Wettkonto haben. Das konnte ich jetzt nicht nochmal verifizieren, aber es steht in manchen Berichten so drin. Und da wir jetzt ja auch Haftbefehle haben, also das ist jetzt alles eine Entwicklung der letzten Tage, gegen 17 Schiedsrichter gibt es Haftbefehle und gegen zwei Präsidenten, muss man ja davon ausgehen, also da ist was. Und da ist dann vielleicht auch mehr, als die haben jetzt nur mal privat für sich eine Wette abgeschlossen. Denn sonst, in meinem Verständnis nach, korrigiere ich gerne, wenn ich da irgendwie auf dem Schlauch stehe, aber dann dürfte es ja sonst kein Haftbefehl geben. Es muss ja dann eigentlich schon einen manipulativen Verdacht zumindest geben.
Ja, also gebe ich dir recht, definitiv. Es geht ja los mit dem Präsidenten des Schiedsrichterverbandes, der eben auch ein Konto hat, ein Wettkonto.
Das ist doch unfassbar.
Wo er dann gesagt hat, da muss ich ein bisschen lachen, wo er dann gesagt hat, ja, ich habe dieses Wettkonto, aber das habe ich nie. Ich habe nie drüber gespielt. Ich habe den nur zur Beobachtung der Spiele oder der Mannschaften. Keine Ahnung. Da habe ich geguckt, mit großem Auge, habe gesagt, what?
Es gibt ja keine anderen Apps, mit denen man Spiele beobachten kann. Ich verstehe es total.
Du hast auch ein Flash-Score, wo du das ebenfalls machst. Du musst schon ein Wertkonto. Das ist klar. Wie gesagt, da war für mich auch klar, da stimmt auch irgendwas nicht. Fakt ist, ich sage es nochmal ganz klar, für mich ist in den unteren Ligen wird ganz klar gehandelt. Ganz klar, von allen Seiten. Schiedsrichter, vielleicht wurden sie auch angewiesen, also jetzt nicht, dass der Schiedsrichter selber draufkommt und sagt, ich mache das jetzt, sondern der wird vom Verband irgendwie darauf angewiesen. Keine Ahnung, das kann ich mir alles gut vorstellen. Spieler und so weiter. Da wirkt die Mafia groß, bin ich mir ziemlich sicher. So wie man eben, und da gehe ich auch, ich glaube nicht, dass man einfach mal so die Ugandische Liga tippen kann. Ich glaube auch dort, also ist ja nicht von Interesse, aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, wenn, egal wo, mafiatechnisch ziemlich groß was drin ist und du das wetten kannst, dass diese Spiele manipuliert sind. Und das kannst du eben mit Uganda machen, das kannst du machen mit, was weiß ich, Singapur oder so. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, welche Ligen da klein genug sind, damit man das machen kann und eben die unteren Ligen der Türkei. Und da bin ich mir ganz sicher, dass dort alles geht. Ich glaube, also sind wir ganz lüchtern betrachtet. Wir wissen seit Corona, dass Fußball nicht nur ein Sportart ist, sondern systemrelevante Ereignisse. Das alles über überdauern kann, dass dort die Staatsanwaltschaft nicht einfach hingeht und sagt, so jetzt aus Verdacht machen wir das jetzt ganz vorsichtig. Da muss man ganz vorsichtig sein. Und wenn man in einem ganz vorsichtigen Thema so sich weit nach vorne lehnt, dann ist da nicht zu 100, sondern zu 1000 Prozent was dran. Die Frage ist eben nur, in welchem Maße. Und deswegen haben sie geguckt, mal gucken, wie weit das geht, wie weit wir das spreaden können. Und es ging tatsächlich eben so weit, dass es ein bisschen in die Super League geht, auch wenn das eben Spieler sind. Und deswegen sieht man ja auch, dass das eben nur türkische Spieler sind und eben keine ausländischen. Dass das eben Leute sind, die aus von unten kommen, sag ich mal, aus den Amateurbereichen nach oben und die dann eben selber dort auch schon gespielt haben. Und das ist eigentlich auch der Beweis eigentlich für mich.
Ja, aber das sind ja die Spieler, das verstehe ich auch alles. Aber wie groß, glaubst du, ist jetzt das Problem bei den Schiedsrichtern? Weil wenn es gegen 17 einen Haftbefehl gibt. Ich habe jetzt aber ehrlicherweise nicht mehr genau nachgeguckt. Da sind jetzt auch wenige, die in der obersten Liga pfeifen mit drin. Aber trotzdem, das ist ja insofern auch ein Problem, weil du brauchst ja auch Schiedsrichter, gute Schiedsrichter, um Wettbewerb aufrechtzuerhalten.
Das ist jetzt werden hier viele Schiedsrichter aus dem Verkehr gezogen. Zu Recht auch. Zumindest das, was ich weiß. Ich möchte hier niemanden irgendwie was Böses. Jetzt hast du also der Präsident, der Verbandspräsident meinte auch letztens keine Angst, wir haben noch genug Schiedsrichter, um die Liga so weiterzuführen.
Na super.
Genau. Aber das heißt ja eben, genau, wenn da jetzt, weiß ich nicht, über 100 Schiedsrichter wegfallen jetzt, dann hast du schon ein Problem für die Zukunft. So schnell kriegst du eben keine. Gerade nicht in dem Land, wo es überhaupt nicht erstrebenswert ist, für Kinder und Jugendliche zu sehen, ah ja, ich werde Schiedsrichter, das ist richtig cool. Nee, eben nicht. Und das sehen sie. So, und so hast du dir jetzt ein extremes Nadelöhr geschaffen. Na ja, was heißt, es klingt jetzt so, als ob ich die Schuld beim Link suche, beim Präsidenten. Das ist es ja nicht. Es ist ja wie es ist. Und deswegen, da werden jetzt natürlich, es geht immer um die unteren Bereiche, da kann ich mir vorstellen, zweierlei. Erstmal, wie gesagt, vom Verband, weil der ist genauso verdächtig, der Schiedsrichterverband, dass da von oben was kam, mach das, mach dies. Mach jenes. Oder eben, die Mafia direkt zu den Schiedsrichtern kommen und sagen, du kriegst so und so, mach es. Und das Geld ist einfach attraktiver als die Gehälter, die sie dort bekommen. Das ist auch Fakt. Deswegen funktioniert es ja da unten. Es funktioniert da unten und eben nicht, ich weiß gar nicht jetzt, ich müsste lügen, ich weiß nicht, was ein Schiedsrichter in der Super League verdient, ehrlich gesagt. Aber davon kannst du schon gut leben. So und eben in der dritten oder vierten Liga eben nicht. Und dann, jetzt kommt die Charakterfrage eben. Weil dann frag ich mich zum Beispiel, okay, warum ist das in anderen Ländern nicht so? Und da ist eben so und jetzt werden vielleicht einige Türken dann auch sagen, wie redet er eigentlich über die Türkei? Aber leider so ist es so. Wir sind oder nicht wir, die Türken sind einfach Geldgeier, bierig. Das Geld ist alles in der Türkei. Es geht alles über das Geld. Wenn du Geld hast, was du machst und Werte wie, ja, Standhaftigkeit, Disziplin, Gutherzigkeit und keine Ahnung was. Also gutherzig sind sie schon teilweise natürlich. Aber so Disziplin, Standhaftigkeit und so weiter, die fallen sehr weit runter. Das hat auch Bedingt, jetzt kann ich jetzt politisch übergehen mit der Inflation des Landes und so weiter und so fort. Die Leute wissen nicht, wie sie über den Tag kommen. All das spielt rein in die Hand der Wettmafia. Ganz klar. Die dann sagen, die dann direkt zum Schiedsrichter gehen und sagen als Beispiel, so und so, kriegst du das und das, machst du bitte das. Dann wiegt dir das ab, ich kriege das für dieses Spiel oder ich kriege das, wenn ich das mache. Da ist das für viele dann keine Frage mehr.
Und wenn du das das erste Mal gemacht hast, kommt die Mafia und sagt, wenn du nicht das nächste Mal wieder machst, dann sagen wir, was du beim ersten Mal gemacht hast.
Dann bist du drin. Einmal gemacht, bist du drin. Und wie gesagt, für mich ist auch der Präsident, der der der der der Schiedsrichter-Komitee höchst suspekt. Ich kann ihm nichts beweisen. Ich habe auch jetzt auch staatsanwaltschaftlich konnte jetzt mal nichts bewiesen werden, nur dass er dieses Wettkonto hat. Dass er für Recherche braucht. Keine Ahnung.
Ja, und es sind einfach komische Sachen passiert. Also wir hatten es ja schon im Frühjahr 2022, dass im laufenden Spielbetrieb 13 Schiedsrichter, die bis dahin in der Super League gepfiffen haben, bis zum Saisonende suspendiert wurden. Und so richtig weiß man bis heute nicht, warum eigentlich.
Ja, genau. Und das ist, es passieren, wie du schon sagst, komische Sachen. Es gibt noch einen Fall, der ist jetzt so ein bisschen ab, gehört aber auch zum Schiedsrichterwesen. Es gab eine Geschichte von einer Schiedsrichterfrau, diesen Namen ich jetzt leider vergessen habe. Sie ist jetzt mittlerweile, ist sie Social Media Phänomen oder wie sich das nennt, keine Ahnung. Und die hatte immer auch gute Spiele bekommen, auch im Amateurbereich trotzdem. Kam dann im Endeffekt raus, dass sie ein Verhältnis zu dem Schiedsrichter Obmann hatte, die für sie zuständig war. Warum ich das erzähle, ist einfach das Ding, dass Schiedsrichterwesen gleichzusetzen mit Seriosität, Fairness, OSW und noch ein paar andere Attribute. Und das ist in der Türkei durch diese Geschichten, die man immer wieder hört, auch durch komische Geschichten, die du gerade erwähnt hast, warum passiert so was, ohne dass man es weiß, passt einfach gut zusammen, wo man dann sagt, ja, okay, hier stimmt was nicht. Generell bin ich bei den Schiedsrichtern, wenn es in der Super League angeht oder auch in der zweiten Liga, halte ich die für sauber. Nicht super ausgebildet, aber für sauber. So. Aber da unter, eben wie gesagt, weil der Fokus nicht da drauf ist, für sehr schmutzig. Und das ist halt so das Ding, dass dieses Schiedsrichterwesen, nicht im Allgemeinen, aber sehr viele Leute und auch Leute, die in gewissen Positionen sind, einfach Dreck am Stecken haben und dass sich dann wie so ein, ja, wie so, wie so Äste sich dann praktisch durch die ganzen Ligen und Verbände durchzieht.
Ja, Menschen sind sich ja gleich, das ist egal, woher du kommst, aber die Strukturen sind ebenso unterschiedlich. Und da hast du ja sehr viele Dinge jetzt genannt. Also ich glaube nicht, dass sich der Charakter da so groß unterscheidet, von Menschen, aber wenn du eben in einem gewissen, in einer Umgebung aufwächst, dann prägt das das sein. Da kann man ja ganz philosophisch werden.
Ich möchte dir ganz höflich widersprechen. Also ich bin hier in Deutschland geboren, aufgewachsen, bin Deutscher und bin auch Türkei und ich kenne beide, ja wie soll ich sagen, beide kulturell sehr gut. Und ich sehe beim Deutschen eine Disziplin, die da ist und auch ein Ehrgefühl, die dann durchgezogen wird. Ich rede nicht generell, ich rede generell und nicht in Einzelfälle. Natürlich gibt es Einzelfälle, die dann auch scheiße sind, keine Frage. Und in der Türkei, das sind keine schlechteren Menschen per se, aber durch diese, was dort alles passiert, durch die Situation, sind sie dann irgendwann, ich glaube jeder Mensch wird dann auch irgendwann denken, okay, das, das, das.
Ja, das meine ich ja, die Umgebung, die formt dich.
Genau, die Umgebung. Ja, also mit Strukturen dachte ich, du meinst hier so innerhalb der TFF oder innerhalb der...
Ach so, nein, nein, ich meinte, ich meinte es ganz allgemein.
Ja, okay, sorry, da hast du natürlich recht.
Ja, richtig. Ich wollte bloß diese vermeidliche Pauschalisierung ein bisschen einordnen und erklären, weil ich versuche immer Klischees zu vermeiden, ehrlich gesagt passt mir das auch nicht so ganz, dass das jetzt auch der türkische Fußball da wieder diesem Klischee so erlegt. Und deswegen bin ich froh, dass wir jetzt aber zum Beispiel schon mal die Spielerseite so aufklären konnten. Was aber so ein bisschen dann für mich so die Frage ist, wenn man jetzt dann nach vorne blickt. Also bei den Spielern scheint es mir so zu sein, dass das gut aufgearbeitet werden kann und dass es vor allem gar nicht so sehr in den Profibereich rein ragt. Bei den Schiedsrichtern und Schiedsrichterinnen, da haben wir jetzt aber noch mal ein anderes Thema. Wie glaubst du denn, geht es jetzt weiter? Und was muss deiner Meinung nach passieren, um jetzt dann, hier sprechen wir jetzt dann doch über die Strukturen im TFF, um da die Strukturen zu schaffen, dass man Schiedsrichterei attraktiv halten kann und trotzdem aber auch in einem Rahmen, der der Liga angemessen ist und der Begeisterung für die Liga angemessen ist. Weil das scheint ja aktuell nicht so zu sein.
Das ist eine sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr schwierige Frage. Denn wie willst du in einem Land, wo Leute sehen, wo jeder sehen kann, wie Schiedsrichter behandelt werden und die selber sie auch so behandeln, wie willst du Leute, wie willst du Jugendliche und Kinder dafür motivieren? Wie willst du, wenn immer wieder solche Geschichten rauskommen, sie dazu motivieren, neutral zu sein, fair zu sein? Dieses Fair Play wird in Türkei im Moment gar nicht geschrieben. Also es ist nicht sichtbar, sage ich jetzt mal so. Bei jeder Fehl-Pfiff-Aktion oder bei jeder Aktion, wo man denkt, wird sofort Manipulation gerufen, wird sofort Skandal gerufen, wird sofort irgendwas, weil die Leute einfach nicht mehr dran glauben. Die glauben einfach nicht mehr an die Fairness des türkischen Fußballs. Da ist so viel kaputt gegangen. Jeder, der jetzt Schiedsrichter werden möchte oder wird, wird es schwierig haben. Ist einfach wie es ist. Wir hatten einmal Glück mit Cenk Cakir, einen wunderbaren Schiedsrichter zu haben, den ich wirklich gefeiert habe ohne Ende, der auch richtig gut war. Und trotzdem, selbst der wurde fertig gemacht in Türkei, wo ich wirkliches Verständnis einfach verliere. Sein Sohn von Cenk Cakir ist ja jetzt auch, oder war auch Schiedsrichter. Ich weiß gar nicht, was mir jetzt mit ihm passiert ist. Der kam und dann haben sie gesagt, hier kommt ein Nachwuchsschiedsrichter. Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob der jetzt noch Schiedsrichter ist oder nicht, weil ich habe nichts mehr gehört seit über einem Jahr. Jetzt. Es ist echt schwierig. Es ist traurig. Also ich bin ja selber Schiedsrichter gewesen. Ich bin ja selber zum Lehrgang gegangen hier in Deutschland. Und wenn ich das mal so vergleiche, dann kommst du dahin, hast so einen 3-Tage-Trip, wo du dann alles lernst und wo du dann dein Regelheftchen bekommst und so weiter und so fort und dann losgehst und machst und tust und ich glaube auch, dass innerhalb des Schiedsrichter-Daseins die Leute sehr, sehr gut zusammenhalten. Richtig. Also ich habe auch der Situation geschuldet einfach, dass die noch enger zusammenrücken. Aber wie gesagt, von außen, das jetzt attraktiv zu machen und wenn du jetzt fragst, was könnte man besser machen, kann ich nur sagen, die Gegebenheiten im Allgemeinen müssten sich schon erst mal ändern komplett. Das ist beim Fußball dieselbe Frage wie beim Schiedsrichter. Also wenn ich jetzt, wie kann man, keine Ahnung, den Verein besser machen, besser führen? Das ist genau wie beim Schiedsrichter. Es liegt, du musst vom Grunde an eigentlich alles erneuern. Du musst dein Mindset ändern. Und du musst sehr viel und was wir leider in Türkei einfach nicht haben, sehr viel Geduld haben. Und die ist einfach nicht da. Und wenn du keine Geduld hast, es gibt mal so ein Sprichwort, das hieß, ein Mann mit Zeit und Geduld könnte alles schaffen. Wir haben nichts von den dreien.
Das ist ein fürchterliches Fazit.
Ja, es ist leider, ich würde dir gern ein schöneres Fazit geben, aber es ist, wie gesagt, ich beobachte diesen Sport, also den Fußball seit 30 Jahren. Und ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich immer sagen wollte, jetzt wird es besser, jetzt wird es besser, jetzt wird es besser, jetzt wird es besser. Es wird immer schlimmer.
Du, wenn du dich mit Gala-Fans unterhältst, herzliche Grüße hier in meiner Nachbarschaft. Die haben einem auch im Sommer noch erzählt, dass Gala innerhalb der nächsten drei Jahre die Champions League gewinnt, so wie es ja auch der Plan ist mit den ganzen Investitionen und so. Und wenn man dann so leichte Skepsis äußert, so ein bisschen, weil man ja ein gebranntes Kind ist, wir haben das ja schon mehrmals erlebt, und dass es eben nie nachhaltig so war, dass es der türkische Fußball in die europäische Spitze reingeschafft hat, dann erntet man nur Unverständnis oder es wird einem Hass unterstellt. Aber das ist ja das Deprimierende. Also sportlich gesehen gibt es ja gerade wieder Dinge, die nach vorne gehen. Und auch was das Nationalteam angeht, natürlich in der Achterbahnfahrt, die dazu gehört, die aber jetzt auch nicht so untypisch ist für Nationalteams, aber was konnte man auch für positive Geschichten über eben den türkischen Fußball erzählen? Und leider kommen immer wieder solche Themen auch mit rein. Und dann springt natürlich so jemand wie ich auch drauf, immer auf die negativen Themen, was natürlich auch super ätzend ist, eigentlich für die komplette Liga und alle Fans.
Ja, aber was machst du denn, Max? Du machst doch nur deinen Job.
Ja, klar, glaube ich, mache ich auch nicht auch.
Da passiert was. Du sagst ja nicht, ich will jetzt auch dauerhaft, warte ich jetzt, bis die mal, die machen das schon selber. Also das verstehen wir Türken nicht anscheinend, immer sich schön in die Opferrolle stellen. Ihr wollt immer nur Schlechtes von uns. Nein, also wenn du sagst, wir hatten auch mal schöne und positive, ja, aber für mich ist das da oben eine komplette Achterbahn. Das ist, wenn das hier der riesen Eisberg ist, ganz da oben, da oben redest du nur. Da passieren manchmal gute Sachen. Alles da unter ist, solange das nicht gelöst wird, können wir zumindest nicht dauerhaft irgendwas erreichen. Die Gala hat vor 25 Jahren den UEFA Cup gewonnen. Danach waren sie ein Jahr später im Viertelfinale der Champions League und danach ging es nur noch bergab. Ich möchte sagen, ja, es war mal eine Situation da, die, was ich jetzt aber auch sagen muss, sich zu wiederholen scheint tatsächlich, weil so hat Gala damals auch angefangen. Und jetzt sind sie tatsächlich auf einem guten Weg. Ob das jetzt für irgendwas reicht, möchte ich jetzt nicht sagen. Aber auf jeden Fall ist das im Moment ein Hoch bei Gala, keine Frage, weil sie jetzt im Moment eine Projektmannschaft sind, ist einfach so. Aber es geht immer darum, es ist einfach nach oben zu kommen und es ist schwierig, oben zu bleiben. Und dieses Schwierig-oben-zu-bleiben, das habe ich bei den Türken noch nicht gesehen. Diese Kontinuität fehlt einfach.
Ja, ja gut. Und dann eben die Struktur. Also du kannst noch so gut als Einzelteam sein und vielleicht auch international mal was reißen, wenn du weiter Probleme hast, gute SchiedsrichterInnen zu finden, wenn du weiter in einem total überhitzten Umfeld, in dem Grautöne keine Rolle mehr spielen, versuchst irgendwas zu entwickeln. Also genau das, was du mit Zeit und Geduld gesagt hast. Ich glaube, dass das ein bisschen das Problem von ganz vielen Fußballliegen ist, weil es ist einfach so viel Emotion mit dabei und so viel Aufmerksamkeit drin. Und gerade die Journalistinnen und Journalisten brauchen ja auch jedes kleine Informationsding, dass man so eine Geschichte aufbauschen kann. Also so richtig geduldig ist da eigentlich keiner im Fußball. Aber dafür geht es da um zu viel Geld. Aber es wäre letztlich das, was man bräuchte und das, was man auch, wo ich auch mal dachte Anfang der 2000er, man wäre vielleicht genau da, weil da ja auch die Weiterentwicklung des Nationalteams und dann WM 2002 und so weiter und so fort, das schien so quasi aufeinander aufzubauen. Aber dann leider ging dann irgendwann, hat man dann gesehen, es war doch nur die Auffahrt zur Achterbahnabfahrt, die ist dann wieder abgefahren.
Ich kann ja genau erzählen, warum es wieder zur Abfahrt, was würde jetzt hier zu lang dauern einfach. Es gibt einfach Sachen, die in der Türkei niemand sieht. Wenn ich mit Deutschland dann mal nur als Beispiel, wenn ich da sehe, wer da den Verein leitet, welche Leute leiten den Verein, guck dir doch mal Bayern München an. Das sind alles ehemalige Spieler. Und nur als Beispiel, Bayern München ist für mich der bestgeführtesten Verein der Welt. Nur mal so das Nummer nebenbei. Und dann guck dir mal an bei Gala. Alles Geschäftsleute. Sorry, dass ich Gala sage, ich meine in der türkischen Liga. Aber auch Gala, alle. Also nur Geschäftsleute, die eben sich profilieren wollen. Sich profilieren wollen, weil sie haben Geld, aber sie sind nicht berühmt einfach. Und sie wollen sich darüber berühmt machen und zeigen. Wenn du Geld hast, aber du hast keine Macht über irgendwas, dann bringt sie das auch nicht. Bzw. für Leute, die das gerne brauchen. Es gibt natürlich Leute, die haben Geld und ziehen sich gerne zurück. Okay, aber wenn das nicht der Fall ist, dann brauchst du eine Plattform, eine Bühne. Und die benutzen diese Mannschaften als Bühne. Deswegen frage ich mich auch z.B., warum die sich nie richtig zusammengetan haben, um gegen sowas vorzugehen, weil sich jeder nur um sich selbst kümmert. Gala denkt jetzt, dass sie durch die Position, die sie jetzt haben, dem entfliegen können. Können sie aber nicht. Weil die Strukturen innerhalb des Fußballs, innerhalb des ganzen gesamten Fußballwesens mit den Schiedsrichtlern, in allem Drum und Dran, eben komplett neu aufgelebt werden muss und verändert werden muss. Solange sie sich da nicht zusammensitzen, zusammentun, kann niemand dem entgehen. Und das heißt, dann flüchtet einmal ganz kurz Gala und kommt dann wieder auf den Tatsachen des Bodenes zurück. Ganz klar. Also, das ist, das ist eine, sowas haben wir immer wieder erlebt. Sowas wird sich immer wieder holen.
Okay, dann habe ich noch eine letzte Frage. Was glaubst du kommt jetzt noch in diesen Skandal? War das jetzt schon die Spitze des Eisbergs? Wir nehmen ja quasi auf in der ständigen Angst vor der nächsten Pressemitteilung, die während dieser Sendung rauskommt. Oder glaubst du, wir haben jetzt das Schlimmste hinter uns?
Also, das werden, das habe ich ja gesagt am Anfang noch, Trainer und Funktionäre jetzt auch noch vernommen. Und allein wenn ich jetzt nur an einen Trainer denke, den Trainer vom Besiktas, Sergi Nyalcan, jeder wird jetzt wissen, was ich jetzt sagen möchte, also jeder der Türken, der ist ja bekannt für Wetten. Also der ist ja bekannt für Pferderennen. Der ist bekannt für ein ekstratisches Leben. Der hat, wenn ich das mal ganz kurz einwerfen kann, im Jahr 2003 hat er in dem Champions League Spiel gegen Chelsea auswärts auf sich selber getippt, dass er zwei Tore schießt. Das hat er auch gemacht. Also, und das war so offen. Also das war so offensichtlich und so. Und jetzt ist er Trainer und er ist jetzt auch aktiver Trainer. Und es werden ja Trainer auch aktive und auch nicht aktive werden jetzt praktisch durchleuchtet. Also klar werden die was bei ihm finden, weil wir wissen es ja auch alle. Wie geht man denn damit jetzt um? Also die Frage ist natürlich dann auch genau wann hat er jetzt immer gewettet? Wettet er dann? Okay, dann sagt er ja das Pferdewetten. Also hat er mit Fußball nichts zu tun und so weiter und so fort. Also da wird glaube ich noch was kommen. Also Funktionäre. Also ich glaube, wir haben also auf deine Fragen kann ich mal so sagen. Ich glaube, da kommt noch einiges auf uns zu. Weil wir haben jetzt, glaube ich, eher noch die unschuldigeren Leute durchleuchtet.
Okay.
Das ist meine Vermutung, ja. Und Funktionäre. Also ich glaube, wenn sie es richtig machen und richtig durchleuchten und alles, wenn die es so machen, wie sie es bei den Schiedsrichtern und bei den Spielern gemacht haben, dann glaube ich, kommt noch einiges auf uns zu. Und auch wir haben ja jetzt schon mit dem Präsidenten von Eibsball eine Gefängnisstrafe. Kannst du dir vorstellen, wo das auch noch hingehen kann alles. Also ich bin sehr gespannt, dass das wird. Auch diese Saison wird eine Saison, wo der Fußball bei weitem nicht in meinem Vordergrund steht. Ja, also für mich war, als das rauskam, war für mich die Saison eigentlich schon gelaufen. Also ich weiß jetzt nicht, wer Meister wird und so. Ist aber auch relativ wurscht. Wie weit kommt man in den Europa Cup? Ja, okay, das ist von Interesse natürlich auch allgemein für die nächste Jahr. Kommen wir zur WM nicht, auch Interesse. Aber das wird uns definitiv bis zum Saisonende und darüber hinaus noch begleiten, ziemlich sicher.
Gökhan, das spricht sehr dafür, dass ich mich nochmal bei dir melde. Bei den Funktionären, da habe ich schon so ein bisschen reinrecherchiert. Da gibt es ja, ich sag mal, schillernde Persönlichkeiten. Das ist ja wie in Deutschland in den 80ern, wo es eben auch so viele so Menschen, die zu Geld gekommen sind und die dann eben auch zu Ruhm kommen wollen und deswegen Präsident werden.
Deswegen, das sage ich ja, das sind keine Sportler. Das sind ja erst Recht, Geschäftsmänner. Und ich glaube, da kommt, also, der Ding kommt noch.
Gut, dann melde ich mich dann da bei dir. Für den Moment aber Gökhan Yagmur von transfermarkt.de. Vielen, vielen Dank, dass du mit dabei warst im Rasenfunk.
Sehr gerne. Vielen Dank auch.
Und ich danke natürlich auch euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern, denn ihr wisst ja, der Rasenfunk ist paywall-werbe- und sponsorenfrei, unter anderem, weil wir mit Sportwetten nichts zu tun haben wollen. Deswegen ganz herzlichen Dank an alle da draußen, die diese Sendung hier auch möglich gemacht haben. Nämlich durch eure freiwillige Unterstützung. In der Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei mehrwerder im Rasenfunk. Ich hoffe, das war jetzt das richtige Thema, an dem du hier genannt wirst. HT bei Jan, bei KSC-Fans 2001, beim Stadionfahrer 1898. Herzliche Grüße und bei Härtelinho auf rasenfunk.de. Da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann, auch in der Videobeschreibung und in der Podcastbeschreibung. Jeder Betrag hilft und davon bekommen dann auch unsere Gäste ein kleines Honorar. In diesem Sinne, danke für eure Unterstützung. Danke, dass ihr den Rasenfunk möglich macht. Unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de könnt ihr sehr gerne Feedback zu dieser Sendung hinterlassen. Und dann freue ich mich, euch bald hier wieder zu hören. Vielleicht ja in einer anderen Sendung. Macht's gut und bis dann. Ciao! Das war der Rasenfunk. Wir geben nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser. Rasenfunk unterstützen ihr Knausa.